faire des choses dire que ça ma part que
nous par contre donc exprimé des colères
et présenter des revendications qui sont
déjà dans l'activité sociale depuis des
mois des années problème de la santé
problème de l'année services publics qui
sont sacrifiés problème des attaques de
monsieur marc compte sur les doigts sous
les acquis problème des retraités et des
personnes âgées problème de
l'envahissement des sargasses problème
du chlordécone et des autres pesticides
problème de non respect des décisions de
justice lorsque ces décisions de justice
de soba du coup le seul qui dirige donc
c'est vraiment un ensemble de sujets qui
ont provoqué un mécontentement et qui
sont quittes
nous espérons le plus fortement dans la
rue le 28